bien bonjour à toutes et à tous le
Rachid adati et Philippe Vigier étaient
en train d'échanger à l'instant
puisqu'il partageent le même officier de
sécurité qui fut celui de Rachida et qui
est aujourd'hui celui de Philippe comme
quoi il y a de il y a de belles
continuités dans les engagements y
compris dans celles et ceux qui nous
entourent merci d'être ici je vais vous
présenter en quelques mots nos
intervenants et introduire au fond ce
qui fait écho à ce que disait d'ailleurs
agè pagch tout à l'heure en disant
finalement nos valeurs républicaines et
nos valeurs démocratiques sont plus
aussi désirables euh dans les autres
pays du monde et parfois sont pas
désirables non plus pour nos
concitoyennes et nos concitoyens et
c'est bien une des raisons de nos
engagements donc vous avez parmi les
intervenants de ce matin je va les
présenter en une phrase parce que vous
les connaissez déjà fort bien d'abord
Rachel Cann qui était venu au cours de
journée parlementaire lorsque je
présidais le groupe modem ouvrir ces
journées parlementaires et qui depuis
euh est une une compagnonne de route
fidèle de notre famille politique même
si je pense qu'elle se serait bien
dispensé lors de cette rentrée
d'être attaqué comme elle l'a été lors
de l'affaire Médine vous vous en
souvenez et il faut comme elle le dit
elle-même pour que une afro yédiche soit
traitée de raciste d'extrême droite il
faut quand même en mettre beaucoup dans
le débat public et donc vous pouvez
l'applaudir et la soutenir par vos
applaudissements
voilà
et et François Baayou me souffle que de
surcroix en plus elle elle a adhéré on
lui a même pas fait une carte gratuite
he
voyez Marie-Pierre vedren qui est à mes
côté que vous connaissez également très
bien qui a en un mandat de de
parlementaire européenne affirmer à la
fois sa position sa stature et qui est
devenue co-présidente de notre famille
alors que nous n'étions pas les plus
nombreux je regarde Sylvie au Parlement
européen et comme quoi le la qualité
l'habileté le savoir-faire breton
peuvent être reconnu à l'échelle
européenne vous pouvez l'appudir
également Rachid hadti je n'ose pas vous
la présenter elle n'est pas seulement la
reine des punchlin des radios et des
télés du matin elle n'est pas seulement
à ce titre un des cauchemars de la mer
de Paris qui pour un certain nombre de
Parisiens enfin ce n'est justice parce
que la mère de Paris fait aussi VI des
au Parisien c'est voilà je vous le fais
pas dire
euh mais je suis très heureux queelle
soit avec nous parce que son son regard
son expérience qui est aussi une
expérience européenne une expérience
gouvernementale et une expérience d'élus
local va pouvoir éclairer ce débat sur
le les valeurs républicaines et puis
bien sûr Philippe Vigier notre tout
nouveau ministre que je veux saluer
amicalement parce que il fait partie de
ceux qui ont fait en sorte que la grande
famille du centre ne soit jamais
totalement désunie depuis 20 ans
d'engagement et donc je suis très
heureux de le retrouver ainsi et dans
des responsabilités
nouvelles alors on va parler on va
parler valeur valeurs républicaines
pacte républicain parce qu'en effet on
fait tous le constat les uns et les
autres que auront des réussites de notre
majorité il y a une réussite économique
mais que l'économie fait pas toujours le
bonheur même si nul n'aurait pensé que
on puisse atteindre ce niveau d'emploi
de croissance mais on voit tant dans le
les fils d'attente qui s'accumulent
devant les restos du cœur que dans un
mal-être qui s'étendent dans la société
et les risques d'extrémistes à
d'extrémisme à gauche ou à droite on
voit bien que il faut que nous
redonnions acuité et actualité aux
valeurs républicaines celles-ci sont
aujourd'hui
bousculé testé dans un débat public qui
est parfois trop trusté par les extrêmes
de gauche et de droite citons les les
filles et les reenes qui sont pas les
plus intelligents mais les plus sonores
qui sont censé être
contraire alors que parfois on les
ressent complice mais entendez-les
parler des
valeurs la valeur de liberté
euh la dernière fois que j'ai entendu
parler de liberté dans la bouche de LFI
c'était pour expliquer que la liberté
c'est la liberté de porter la BAA
parlez-en aux femmes afghanes je suis
pas sûr qu'elles aent le la même
conception la dernière fois que j'ai
entendu parler d'égalité c'était euh euh
au rassemblement national qui protestait
dans son dans son mutisme désormais
encravaté de son républicanisme euh mais
euh au fond dans une des pierres
angulaire euh n'est jamais que une forme
de préférence ethnique le la fraternité
foulé au pied également parce qu'au fond
s'organise dans notre société euh les
fraternités les solidarités uniquement
avec ceux qui sont d'accord avec nous
et
puis avec ce triptique républicain Nous
ajoutons toujours la laïcité je regarde
François cette laïcité qui qui tantôt
est utilisée comme une arme pointée
contre certaines communautés et tantôt
euh traité de dérivve d'extrême droit
d'outils
euh du racisme donc nous avons besoin à
la fois de redéfinir ce que sont les
valeurs de regarder comment on peut les
défendre et surtout comment en agissant
on leur redonne une actualité donc j'ai
envie de commencer euh avec Rachel can
pour que elle nous donne son point de
vue sur cette sur ces risques et les
dangers qui guettent nos valeurs merci
beaucoup je suis ravie d'être présente
aujourd'hui et juste un propos liminire
euh
oui il y a cette histoire de la fin de
l'été euh euh mais qui était assez
révélatrice et au fond c'est pas moi qui
a été attaqué mais c'est c'est la
République qui a été attaquée et dans
ces moments-là je tiens vraiment à
remercier François Baayou de son soutien
constant et et de rappeler et son équipe
aussi et et de rappeler que je suis
heureuse d'être ici aussi parce que je
sais que on on m'impute beaucoup de
choses et on on projette sur moi
beaucoup de choses mais je fais partie
de la famille modem je tenais à le dire
devant vous
aujourd'hui concernant le pacte
républicain et les valeurs je voulais
revenir sur le mot valeur parce que ce
que veut dire valeur c'est pas principe
mais c'est comment redonner finalement
cette richesse à nos principes
fondamentaux valeur liberté égalité
c'est un trésor républicain c'est un
trésor universaliste mais c'est un
trésor humaniste qui veut dire faire
progresser nos humanités alors c'est
vrai que moi j'ai pu le vivre au sein de
ma propre famille avec un père musulman
une mère juive se pédigrer on parl tout
à l'heure d'hybridation dans cette
hybridation là dans cette dans cette
finalement cette mondialisation on en
parlait hier mais juste revenir sur les
valeurs pour qu'on soit d'accord au fond
au début de cette conférence
sur on parle de
quoi liberté égalité fraternité la
démocratie l'état de droit la laïcité et
aussi un principe qui a été rappelé hier
très fortement par Madame surau et
c'était moi ça m'a beaucoup ému
l'égalité devant la loi parce que
l'égalité devant la loi ça veut dire le
principe de non discrimination qui est
préempté
aujourd'hui à l'extrême gauche comme une
forme de monopole de la souffrance
monopole de lutte contre les
discriminations mais nous en fait ce que
nous nous avons à à à redorer c'est le
principe de l'égalité devant la loi et
c'est vrai que finalement pour redonner
du sens il y a à mon avis deux choses
c'est comment repérer dans l'espace
public et politique et médiatique
comment repérer les endroits où notre
pacte républicain est
entaché d'abord et avant tout et ça
commence par les mots et c'est vrai que
le l'ouvrage que avait écrit racé il y a
quelques années ça a commencé par ces
mots qui nous séparent ces mots qui sont
à l'inverse de notre pacte républicain
ces mots qui nous divisent qui pointent
du doigt l'homme blanc de plus de 50 ans
qui pointe du doigt donc le souschien
qui vous qualifie de raciser donc
directement ces mots qui font que nous
sommes que nous ne serions plus
finalement un peuple politique qui se
retrouve autour de ce SoC républicain
mais que nous deviendrions un peuple
ethnique un peuple racial un peuple
religieux et c'est ça d'abord qu'il faut
combattre et en tout cas à mon sens
c'est dès
le les mots dès le au on dit au début il
y avait le verbe et bien c'est ça à mon
avis qu'il faut combattre puissamment
d'abord et avant tout et c'est pour ça
que lorsqu'on me dit mais vous en tant
que racisé c'est quelque chose que que
que je refuse éperdument puisque je suis
une citoyenne d'abord et avant
tout ensuite dans les dans les mots qui
séparent il y a aussi les slogans
aujourd'hui ces slogans tout le monde
déteste la police la police tue le
racisme systémique tout ça ce sont les
débuts en fait qui créent qui imbib la
société et qui commence à qui crée cette
haine entre entre nous et qui nous qui
nous divise et qui fait qu'on peut pas
en fait tous se réunir autour de ce ce
socle républicain et puis il y a ces
méthodes le populisme et là ça réunit
l'extrême en fait l'extrême qu'on
pourrait qualifier d'extrême au
singulier aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire une
bataille contre le
réel avec ces personnes qui font
semblant de vous représenter ou de
représenter des opinions ordinaires euh
contre les riches contre l'élite contre
la culture contre l'exigence contre
l'excellence contre la beauté le beau où
finalement tout serait l'équivalent de
tout mais quand on parle de valeur ça
veut bien dire que tout n'est pas
l'équivalent de tout il y a des choses
qui sont des trésors et d'autres choses
qui sont voilà il y a une hiérarchie
dans les
choses et dans le populisme il y a cette
chose aussi avec un inversement
justement des valeurs avec des personnes
qui
sont mécontentes d'être é trop tard et
qui se font passer pour Robespierre ou
pour Rosa Parks ou pour le tout en même
temps ou pour
drfus et qui alimente cette colère en
s'appuyant sur des névroses sociales
pour créer le chaos et là où il faut
être très vigilant c'est sûr et je veux
pas prendre trop de temps de parole mais
sur la
disqualification dont vous parliez au
début la disqualification disqualifier
l'autre intimider l'autre
avec cette
victimocratie qui vous fait
culpabiliser ce monopole de la
souffrance donc on aurait une partie de
la population en fait des représentants
qui vous disent nous sommes des victimes
parce que nous sommes noirs parce que
nous sommes arabes parce que nous sommes
musulmans parce que nous sommes
femmes et donc qui tirerait un monopole
de cet
essentialisme et qui nous empêcherait en
fait de nous battre contre justement
l'État de droit pour l'égalité devant la
loi donc il faut reprendre en fait ce ce
ce combat là très fortement l'égalité
devant la loi pour faire comprendre que
il y a un inversement parce que
finalement ces personnes qui se
revendiqu le la représentation des Noirs
de France la représentation des
musulmans de France en réalité
font nourrissent finalement l'extrême
l'extrême droite et nous empêchent de
nous battre contre l'égalité devant la
loi et puis tout ça où vous traitez vous
d'extrême droite parce que vous défendez
la laïcité tout ça c'est fait pour vous
faire taire et vous empêcher de
redonner ce trésor républicain que vous
portez avec votre
voix
merci rachel a bien défini le combat euh
orwiien j'allais dire parce que voilà
quand on veut détruire des valeurs quand
on veut les déliter au fond on les
inverse c'est la guerre c'est la pai la
liberté c'est l'esclavage voilà et tout
ça finit dans le
totalitarisme ces inversions de valeurs
Marie- piierre on les a connu dans un
certain nombre de pays européens qui ont
conduit d'ailleurs à l'élection de
l'extrême droite comment à la fois on
les on les fait vivre on les rétabl
quand on est une actrice locale comme
toi et un parlementaire européen et
comment les valeurs ain peuent inspirer
aussi notre action à l'échelon européen
merci beaucoup bonjour à tous je crois
que déjà les deux mots essentiels qui
ont été dit justement pour ce lien entre
l'action locale nationale et européenne
c'est ce que vous avez dit c'est que ces
valeurs elles sont humanistes et elles
sont universelles et ça justement on
doit jamais l'oublier et on doit
toujours le porter et le redire et on le
voit bien ça a été dit dans la table
ronde précédente aussi c'est Sébastien
habis qui l'a dit l'Union européenne
c'est l'espace au monde le plus intégré
et l'espace qui repose justement sur ses
valeurs les valeurs que vous avez cité
bien sûr la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité la laïcité le respect de
l'État de droit et on voit que à l'heure
actuelle au sein même de l'Union
européenne et partout dans le monde
l'État de droit l'indépendance de la
justice et ça fait écho à tout ce que
vous avez dit la liberté de la presse
sont menacés sont menacés dans certains
États-membres parce que effectivement il
y a une instrumentalisation de la part
de certains autocrates qui justement
alimentent ce discours pour pouvoir
garder le pouvoir et mettre à mal tous
ceux qui justement voudraient rétablir
ces valeurs et veulent les promouvoir
parce qu'on a deux enjeux on a être fier
d'affirmer ces valeurs et de les
promouvoir et on a d'être ferme dans
leur défense et ça je crois que parfois
justement on manque sur les deux aspects
et à l'échelle nationale à l'échelle
locale à l'échelle européenne c'est ce
qu'on a fait pendant ce mandat en
travaillant justement aussi sur les
questions de conditionnalité à l'état de
droit notre toute notre travail pendant
ce mandat ça a été dire que on ne veut
plus octroyer d'argent européen le
budget finalement des citoyens européens
à l'échelle locale à des autocrates
européens qui finalement
instrumentalisent justement tous ces
débats et on y est arrivé ça a pas été
facile et on voit bien que notre rôle
c'est justement de toujours pousser la
Commission européenne qui est prise par
toutes ces injonctions contradictoire et
par la pression de certains chefs d'État
et de gouvernement pour véritablement
être ferme justement dans le respect et
dans la promotion de ces valeurs et on
on y arrive on y arrive et parce que
aussi à l'échelle locale je crois que ce
qu'on fait et notre parti le démontre
aussi aujourd'hui et dans tout au long
de universités c'est qu'on est capable
de discuter justement avec tous avec
tous ceux qui veulent défendre ses
valeurs avec tous ceux qui ne partagent
pas nécessairement tous des éléments
mais qui ont par contre ce socle commun
pour pouvoir défendre ses valeurs et ce
qu'on crée aujourd'hui ce que j'ai
essayé de créer aussi pendant tout mon
mandat c'est ces espaces d'écoute et de
dialogue faire en sorte que des gens
aussi qui ne devraient pas toujours se
rencontrer se rencontrent confronte leur
point de vue pour pouvoir revenir sur
ces fondamentaux et c'est tout ça qui
justement contribua réellement à à la
fois promouvoir les valeur et à la fois
les faire défendre avec
fermeté
[Applaudissements]
alors Rachida j'avais bien sûr envie de
vous faire réagir sur ce qui vient
d'être dit mais mais d'abord parce
que Marie-Pierre disait à l'instant au
fond on s'efforce de parler avec des
gens différents de nous les uns et les
autres et la première question que j'ai
envie de vous poser c'est au fond alors
qu'on appartient à des familles de
pensées qui sont différentes mais
pourquoi vous êtes avec nous
aujourd'hui non c'est pas seulement
parce que Gatel vous aime bien même si
c'est le
cas attention ça serait une forme de
stigmatisation là et moi je
cumule non mais merci d'abord je voulais
remercier François baayrou et M Gatel de
m'avoir invité à votre réunion et je
disais à François quand il m'a appelé je
ne savais je ne connaissais même pas le
thème sur lequel j'allais intervenir
j'ai dit oui tout de suite vous pensez
que une étiquette sépare moi je pense
pas qu'une étiquette sépare ce qui peut
n rassembler au-delà des étiquettes
c'est des parcours c'est justement des
valeurs comme l'a dit très justement et
très fortement Rachel et puis des valeur
des sensibilités moi je vais vous le
dire comment j'ai rencontré François
baayrou c'est Simon veille qui nous a
rapproché qui nous a permis de nous
rencontrer il était à l'époque ministre
de l'éducation nationale et tous les
débats que nous avons aujourd'hui sur la
BAA et que sais-je parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est la baaya demain ça sera autre
chose c'était les atteintes graves à la
laïcité dans les établissements
scolaires et je le dis François et je
voudrais avoir une pensée émue pour
Marielle de Sarnez avec laquelle j'ai
beaucoup travaillé et qui a été pour moi
au-delà de la respons politique qu'elle
était ça a été une femme pour moi de
confiance et de confidence et dans le
milieu dans lequel nous sommes la
confiance et la confidence c'est pas
forcément les valeurs qui nous incarnent
vraiment en politique et donc je voulais
avoir cette pensée pour
Mariel il y a une valeur que qu'on
pourrait ajouter c'est celle de la
transmission et cette transmission
Marielle de sarnz évidemment l' donné à
M Gatel que je ne connaissais pas avant
que nous soyons élus ensemble au Conseil
de Paris et je pense que c'est une digne
successeur de Mariel de sarnais je
voulais te le dire publiquement cher
Maude vraiment pour ton travail et pour
ce que tu incares et ce que tu portes et
donc avec François Baayou on s'est connu
à ce moment-là lorsqu'il était ministre
de l'éducation nationale peu soutenu sur
les atteintes à la laïcité en sort
c'estit quand même avec la lâcheté de la
gauche de 89 parce que tous les
problèmes qu'on paye aujourd'hui c'est
quand même la lâcheté de la gauche il
faut le dire en 99 on a été très lâche
sur ce sujet de laïicité comme si
c'était une liberté une atteinte à la
laïicité c'est pas une liberté et si je
suis sur cette scène aujourd'hui en face
à vous c'est que justement sans
préjudice de ce que je suis ni de mon
origine ni du parcours ni de ce que
m'ont donné transmis mes parents mais on
a pu avoir cette communauté de destin
parce que la laïcité nous a protégé nous
a donné la liberté que j'ai aujourd'hui
et à l'époque il y avait des jeunes
filles dans des foyers très durs qui
souhaitaient porter le foulard comme une
liberté et avec
François on avait discuté d'ailleurs ça
m'a permis d'avoir comme éminent
directeur de cabinet Patrick Gérard qui
était ton collaborateur sur ces
questions là et on a pu aller à la
rencontre de ces jeunes filles d'abord
de comprendre de comprendre pourquoi des
jeunes filles nées en France dont pour
certaines les parents étaient nés en
France et subitement porter le foulard
devenait une liberté ou en tous les cas
une liberté identitaire nous avons
réussi François et ça a été c'est vrai
ton succès à les convaincre sans les
contraindre de leur expliquer que
c'était pas leur liberté de pouvoir le
porter que ça allait les entraver y
compris dans leur perspective de vie
mais aussi dans leur perspective de
liberté de conscience parce que le fou
ne leur donnait pas de liberté de
conscience ça donnait un gage à d'autres
et c'est ces autresl que N que nous
avons essayé évidemment d'entraver et et
la loi de 2004
le le précurseur ça a été la circulaire
dit
baayrou que les chefs d'établissement et
la communauté éducative a pu sur
laquelle elle a pu s'appuyer très
fortement et c'est pour ça que de 93 à
2004 qu' k ça a quand même marché et
nous sommes allés jusqu'à la lo de 2004
et ça je je le dis nous le devons à
François baayrou ça a été effectivement
le premier acte politique fort dans la
lutte dans ses atteintes à la laïcité et
moi je le dis avec beaucoup de respect
pour Gabriel Atal en disant c'est une
victoire de la Baya dites là ba demain
ça sera autre chose c'est l'application
de la loif enfin tout à l'heure on
parlait des valeurs ben une valeur c'est
de respecter la loi et à un moment donné
on s'est donné des libertés on s'est
donné des accommodements je n'aime pas
ce mot cet accommodement parce que
l'accommandement c'est nivellement et
certains ça les arrangeait finalement
d'avoir des accommandements avec
certains parce que vous savez très bien
quand vous avez une jeune fille qui
porte le foulard ou autre chose ou des
garçons pour lesquels on le on leur
inculque des principes qui les entravent
aussi on se dit tant mieux parce qu'ils
n'iront pas très loin et moi je mets
aussi en cause bah parfois y compris
chez certains enseignants ou même chez
certains élus d'avoir pas favorisé
forcément je n'irai pas jusque- là mais
en tout cas d'avoir laissé faire en se
disant on se débarrassera d'eux comme ça
et c'est très bien aini comme certains
élus d'ailleurs dans certains quartiers
qui disait ça vote pas on s'en fout
jusqu'au jour où ils viennent vous
brûler bah vos mairies vos écoles et
tous les lieux publi et ça fallait
l'anticiper et pouvoir évidemment le
comprendre on a laissé faire et ça la
valeur qui pour moi est importante c'est
le respect de l'autorité le respect des
institutions le respect de la loi ça
part de là et c'est vrai qu'on a laissé
faire et tout à l'heure un des
interlocuteurs et on s'est fait la
remarque avec François il disait oui moi
je ne suis pas pour l'ascenseur sociale
je suis pour l'escalier social ben moi
je suis pour l'ascenseur social parce
que parfois ça serait bien que ceux qui
sont l'ascenseur il nous laisse un peu
la place parce qu'on en a un peu marre
de prendre l'escalier voilà donc parce
que l'escalier doit pas être forcément
toujours pour les mêmes parce que ça ça
peut mettre en péril le pacte
républicain parce qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui tout commence où moi je me
souviens de ce film de Bertrand
Tavernier tout commence aujourd'hui mais
c'est une leçon de vie ce film et pour
ceux qui ont connu
ou des conditions sociales défavorisé ou
des cités qui étaient au parquet des
gens
et vraiment au dépend de tout bah tout
commence à l'école et notre combat
aujourd'hui oui l'égalité oui
l'ascension sociale oui mais l'égalité
faudrait peut-être réduire les
inégalités qui sont dans les écoles et
aujourd'hui on le voit les inégalités
dans les écoles contrairement ce qui est
dit et compris enfin pardon François tu
appartiens à la majorité présidentielle
votre parti politique mais les
inégalités à l'école se sont aggravé
pourquoi je dises se sont aggravé on
peut après dire statistiquement ça c'est
pas le cas ou pas vous avez vu la fuite
dans les écoles
privées pourquoi parce qu'il y a des
écoles où effectivement ça marche plus
on vous dit il y a un prof devant chaque
gamin ah bah oui parce que quand vous il
manque deux instit et ben vous regroupe
trois classes est-ce qu'il est normal
que le gamin de CM2 soit qu'un instit
CE1 ou que le gamin de CP se retrouve
avec un astit de CM2 au bout d'un moment
bah on paye la facture en 6e on dit
effectivement que vous avez 20 %
d'enfants qui arrivent en 6e sans savoir
lire et et écrire moi mon combat il est
sur l'école et depuis toujours je suis
pour l'école publique et pourtant je ne
suis pas allée à l'école publique parce
que justement mes parents ont compris
très vite que peut-être que l'égalité
était peut-être dans un autre endroit
nous avons été scolarisés mes parents
étaient
musulmans dans
un établissement catholique à l'époque
de jeune fille pourquoi parce que
c'était les vrais établissements
catholiques d'abord ont payé en fonction
de ses revenus et puis les enfants ne
savaient pas combien payaient combien
chaque parent payait et tout le monde
était traité de la même manière mais
aujourd'hui à l'école publique moi je
trouve que la carte scolaire que nous
avions voulu commencer à réformer on a
eu des
résistance je pense aussi que dans cette
salle je blâ pas certains ont essayé de
contourner la carte scolaire parce qu'on
se dit moi j'ai pas envie de me
retrouver avec la cage d'escalier dans
la même classe de retrouver les mêmes
problèmes de ma cage d'escalier dans la
dans la cour d'école et c'est ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui donc oui moi je suis
pour la réduction des inégalités à
l'école je suis pour l'égalité
homme-femme je suis pour la liberté pour
le respect des institutions pour le
respect de l'autorité ce qu'on a essayé
de faire j'étaé magistrat j'ai été
magistrat au tribun de bobini qui est le
plus grand Tribunal des mineurs de
France moi j'ai vu où on pouvait
rétablir l'autorité parfois par l'acheté
on laisse
faire le gamin on lui dit faut aller
chercher les parents puis il viennent
pas avec les parents et on s'en fiche et
puis vient avec un voisin l'autorité
elle commence là si l'institution ne
montre pas l'autorité vis-à-vis des
enfants comment voulez-vous que eux
respectent l'autorité ou croi en
l'autorité parce que le péril moi je
vais vous dire ce qui risque ce qui se
passe au moment des émeutes suite à la
mort de naë oui on peut dire tous ces
jeunes respectent rien c'est l'échec de
l'intégration bien sûr mais est-ce qu'on
s'interroge pourquoi des gamin de 17 ans
sont à 7h du matin dans une voiture ou
voler ou louer euh alors qu'ils sont
encore mineurs et il a 17 ans qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait à 16 qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
à 15 est-ce qu'il y avait un suivi
scolaire est-ce qu'il y avait un suivi
sociojudiciaire les institutions
s'interrogent pas là-dessus on s'est pas
interroger là-dessus moi mon
interrogation c'est comment un aë se
retrouve à 7h du matin dans une voiture
sur un refus d'obtempéré et aussi avec
des antécédents judiciaires quand je dis
antécédents judiciaires c'est pas le
pointer du doigt c'est de dire pourquoi
on en arrive là et comment on en arrive
là et donc aujourd'hui il faut
s'interroger aussi là-dessus c'est bien
de dire
euh faut rétablir autorité faut
respecter la justice l'État de droit je
pense qu'on se gararise beaucoup mais il
y en a beaucoup qui aimeraient euh en
vivre en bénéficier et qui ne l'ont pas
le sujet du logement est un sujet majeur
certains ont dit que c'est une bombe
sociale je crois que c'est une bombe
sociale allez dans des quartiers moi je
je vais parce que je vous n'échappez pas
à votre enfance vous savez d'où vous
venez vous savez ce qui vous a construit
vous savez ce qui vous a pétri moi plus
d'une fois je dis ouais j'en ai marre de
toute façon on lutte on lutte on n'y
arrive pas mais en fait non ça serait
lâche de ma part de partir surtout
aujourd'hui où moi j'ai pris
l'ascenseur donc je fais quoi je je
j'arrive au 46e étage et je le bloque
pour les autres justement non faut le
renvoyer et le seul moyen moi je pense
de le renvoyer c'est notre
responsabilité comme personne politique
engagé c'est notre responsabilité c'est
pas que la faute des autres c'est pas
que la faute des émetiers on a peut-être
une responsabilité on devrait se
regarder on devrait savoir pourquoi à un
moment donné on se retrouve avec toute
une frangeche de la population sans
formation sans qualification ça a été
notre combat François tu l'as mené quand
tu étais ministre de l'éducation
nationale et si qui fait d'ailleurs
qu'on a jamais rompu le lien tous les
deux jamais on s'est toujours appelé tu
as toujours été là y compris quand ça a
été des moments compliqués pour moi tu
as toujours été là pourquoi n'a jamais
rompu le lien parce qu'on a jamais
désespéré sur cette réduction des
inégalités qui fait qu'on peut vivre
ensemble qui est cette communauté de
destin moi je suis d'accord avec Rachel
c'est pas une question religieuse c'est
pas une question culturelle moi mes
parents n'ont pas eu la même vie que vos
parents est-ce qu'on est si différent
parce qu'à un moment donné on s'est
inscrit dans une communauté de destin et
donc les sujets aujourd'hui ça être le
logement savez comment on lutte contre
la désintégration l'école la formation
nous allons voir un débat important sur
l'immigration attention que les extrêmes
l'emportent pas attention à que ce soit
pas celui qui parle le plus fort qu'
l'emporte et ce que je dis là il vaà
pour ma famille politique moi je le dis
c'est pas binaire le débat sur
l'immigration il y a des humains
derrière il y a des gens qui se battent
il y a des gens qui meurent il y a des
gens qui souffrent il y a des gens qui
savent pourquoi ils sont venus donc fait
faut faire attention à ça et
sur et sur l'immigration oui il faut
réguler les flux bien sûr qu'il faut
réguler les flux mais parce que il y a
aucun pays qui accepte que subitement
tout le monde vienne comme ça
s'installer chez eux c'est pas comme ça
parce que là l'intégration marchera plus
donc la régular la régulation des flux
migratoires ben c'est effectivement de
pouvoir travailler avec les pays sources
d'origine j'étais avec une réunion avec
des autorités
enx c'est à 150 km de l'Italie là
maintenant ils mettent des embarcations
ils s'en fichent qu'elle soit pas
tenable il mettre un moteur puissant ça
se propulse ça arrive c'est des norias
sans cesse je suis allé à Lampedusa je
peux vous dire que je tenais des quand
vous allez à l'ampedusa vous réduisez le
le volume sonore ça vous donne une leçon
aussi d'humanité alors après on est
aussi on est responsable la compassion
l'empathie c'est bien mais il faut
prendre des
décisions et le volet sur lequel vous
allez avoir à débattre puisque ça
devient binaire au niveau du débat
public est-ce qu'on régularise les 100
papiers pour les métiers en tension il y
a un débat moi j'entends sa chaoulier
j'entends des gens alors pardon ne
prenez pas dans dans ma bouche une une
attaque mais moi des gens qui ont jamais
bossé qui savent pas ce qui est
l'immigration qui savent pas ce qui est
l'exil ce qui savent pas ce que c'est de
travailler sans papier et ils disent bah
c'est pas grave ceux qui sont qui
occupent déjà ses
on va leur donner des papiers vous
trouvez pas que c'est une facilité moi
ça vous renvoie à mon père des années 60
donc on revient aux années 60 c'est
qu'on dit c'est pas grave travail sans
respect des conditions de travail sans
les les rémunérations on va leur donner
des papiers et puis voilà mais ces
gens-là après ils ont pas de famille ils
font pas d'enfants on donne une carte de
séjour et après on pense plus à ce qu'il
après mais après on va donc on va se
retrouver dans le débat du recroupement
familial de 74 mais il faut arrêter
d'être dans des temps anciens moi je
trouve que de dire faut régulariser dans
les métiers en tenstion c'est une
facilité il faut effectivement pouvoir
comprendre pourquoi ces métiers ention
sont pas pour vous peut-être les
salaires peut-être les conditions de
travail parce qu'on dit oui c'est tous
les emploi que les Français ne veulent
plus faire ah bon moi je ne crois pas
moi j'ai pas de mépris pour les Français
parce que je vous dire quand vous voyez
des femmes qui font le ménage à 5h du
matin dans vos bureaux quand on y est
nous et qui viennent vider les poubelles
qui reviennent à 4h de l'après-midi ou à
6h moi vous savez j'ai été aide
soignante de nuit et de jour j'ai été
caissière où le type vous dit tu viens à
7h tu reviens 14h tu reviens à 18h pour
faire la fermeture pourquoi parce qu'on
a pas le choix parce que c'est comme ça
bah quand vous avez des enfants vous me
vous avez 2 heures de trajet avec les le
R ou autre vous pouvez pas faire garder
vos enfants faut s'interroger aussi sur
les conditions de travail sur les
rémunérations et moi je pense que dire
on régularise les métiers en tension
peut-être que ça peut être le cas comme
on a pu le faire au moment du covid ou
autre mais c'est aussi une facilité
pensez à ce qu'on va faire parce que en
régularisant des gens qui n'ont pas de
papier on régularise pas une personne
c'est un c'est une vie qu'on prend en
charge et la vie élargie de ces
personnes qu'on régularise donc le débat
sur l'immigration il sera pas binaire et
moi ce que je crains c'est que ça se
radicalise et que finalement bah on
s'accommode on va dire c'est pas grave
on va faire de la fermeté et puis c'est
pas très grave on va régulariser on rien
régler rien régler et le sujet majeur
c'est tout le parcours d'intégration et
l'intégration pour des gens qui sont né
en France depuis 4 générations qui ne
sont pas
intégrés la faille elle est où donc là
il faut évidemment qu'on s'interroge sur
sur l'école et et moi je veux bien
entendre je sais que vous allez recevoir
Gabriel Attal après mais il va vous dire
oui il y a des profs devant chaque
enfant interrogez-vous quels sont les
profs devant chaque enfant est-ce que
chaque classe est-ce que chaque niveau
de classe à le bon prof
elle est là la question est-ce que cet
enfant de CP je vais l'emmener dans de
bonnes conditions en
6e tous les enjeux pardon je je vais
d'un sujet à un autre mais le pacte
républicain il est là la promesse
républicaine c'était un sujet de
campagne présidentielle la promesse
républicaine elle est là parce que sinon
honnêtement ça changera pas et ça va
s'aggraver et là on le voit bien sur
l'augmentation de la délinquence ça veut
dire impunité totale on fait on va pas
être attrapé par la patrouille et donc
le sujet et mon ami Philippe pourra le
dire parce que les territoires d'outremè
qu'on oublie sont très concernés par ça
regardez mayott c'est la France hein
réunion Matinique et donc tout à l'heure
il me disait c'est un petit Matignon ce
ce ministère oui parce que c'est la
France et tous ces sujets-là sont
comportés là et donc là moi je vous dire
sur ces débats qui vont venir les débats
qui vont venir pour cette présidence
pour les responsables politiques que
nous sommes
c'est soit l'honneur ou le déshonneur je
vous le dis l'école le logement
l'intégration l'immigration la justice
et l'autorité voilà ce qu'on a à faire
d'ici 4 ans si on si on échoue je sais
très bien ce qui va arriver en
2027 et moi j'entends d'ici ce qu'on va
dire on va dire bah on a essayé de
tendre la main à la droite elle a pas
voulu la prendre puis la gauche ils ont
voulu que de la destruction non on peut
pas se dédoiner comme ça
donc c'est aussi notre responsabilité de
marquer de notre
empreinte sur les 4 années à venir de
pouvoir évidemment reconstruire ce pacte
républicain parce que sinon on va se
gargariser de mot hein on peut revenir
la prochaine refaire les mêmes
conférence et les mêmes choses mais à un
moment donné il faut entendre c'est
comme pardon j'aurais été longue après
je je je laisserai parce que il y a
beaucoup à dire moi je suis très frappé
on dit les violences policières pas les
violences policières et tout moi je suis
devenu magistrat vous savez pourquoi
parce que j'habita dans une cité bien
sûr je suis une famille de 12 enfants on
se connaissait tous dans cette cité moi
mes amis d'enfance bah ils étaient en
centre pénitentiaire ils ont connu la
prostitution ils ont connu la
criminalité y compris la criminalité
organisée voilà mes amis d' enfance moi
je garde j'ai eu un petit moment quand
je suis devenu garde des saut j'avais
des félicitations de personnes qui
étaient détenu qui étaient mes amis
d'enfance et qui me félicitait avec des
enveloppes écrou numéro temp centre
pénitentiaire de tel endroit
bien sûr que ça vous a Meux parce que
vous vous dites pourquoi moi je suis
garde des saut et que l'autre mon voisin
de palier est détenu et pour des longues
peines donc il faut pas se louper
là-dessus je suis devenu magistrat parce
que je me suis dit l'État de droit pour
des gens qui n'ont rien c'est d'être au
plus près de l'État de droit je suis pas
devenu policier je suis devenu magistrat
pour cette raisonlà donc moi je dis pas
qu'il y a des voluances policières je
dis pas que la police est raciste je ne
dis pas que la justice est raciste mais
je dis que dans ces institutions ça peut
exister donc donc moi je pense que le
débat mérite d'être ouvert je vous le
dis avec beaucoup de force et de
conviction et c'est l'ancien magistrat
qui vous le dit et c'est l'ancien garde
des saut qui vous le
dit c'était pas trop long cher Rachida
parce que c'était un moment de sincérité
et de nuances dans le débat même si on
partage pas tout à fait les mêmes
nuances sur chacun de ces thèmes mais en
revanche il y a une ligne de fond où
effectivement on se rejoint c'est qu'il
y a des valeurs républicaines il y a une
promesse qui est derrière en terme de
politique publique et c'est là que
j'aimerais entendre Philippe parce
que on réfléchit en valeur en conviction
et en détermination pour les défendre et
comment on les traduit ensuite sur les
différents sujets évoqués et en
particulier sur les outremèes et puis on
viendra sur d'autres sujets également
parce qu'on a des témoignages sur sur
l'école sur l' SNU sur l'enfance sur la
culture j'aimerais bien aussi entendre
Rachel donc donc on va passer dans une
deuxième partie à comment on défend ses
valeurs et comment on les traduit en en
acte républicain
Philippe bien bonjour à toutes et à tous
d'abord je suis très heureux d'être là
je remercie encore François de d'avoir
fait en sorte qu'on puisse me confier
des très belles responsabilités puis je
vais vous dire une
chose nous sommes dans une famille
politique voyez dans laquelle on
réfléchit souvent les journalistes
disent il se passe plus rien il y a plus
de débat ben non tout à l'heure on
parlait de la confiance dans notre
atelier François la loi confiance de
2017 j'étais avec Isabelle Floren et
Rachel lorsque tu as été attaqué il y a
quelques semaines il y avait tous un peu
de Rachel canne qui a été attaqué au
travers de toi j'avais dit à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a Emmanuel honoré qui est
pas loin qui me regarde qui était mon
collaborateur à l'époque il travaille il
travaille maintenant avec Marc fenau
c'était ma première phrase lorsque la
République est attaquée il faut plus de
République bien en fait ce qui nous
rassemble ce matin c'est de dire comment
on fait vivre plus de République au
travers tous vos témoignages et
Marie-Pierre maintenant que tu es devenu
dans le sigillage de Mariel une
ambassadrce de l'Europe parce que tu as
compris que et bien ces valeurs il
fallait les faire rayonner bien au-delà
de nos frontières d'ailleurs
pardonnez-moi mais l'autre jour lorsque
la première ministre italienne est allée
à Lampedusa quelque part ça montre que
l'Europe est arrivée on était loin d'un
discours qu'elle avait tenu un an avant
et puis ce qu'on vient de dire asashida
elle s'en souvient pas mais il y a 15
ans on avait fait un débat ensemble à PO
à l'initiative de Jean-Pierre rafarin
sur la décentralisation et comment
redonner de la confiance puisque tu
m'interroges Patrick et merci d'avoir
présenté ce débat comme tu l'as fait
avec la profondeur de vue qui la tienne
voyez moi j'arrive de maotte il il y a
une conseiller départemental maores qui
est dans la
salle quand on parle d'égalité des
chances voilà moi je reviens révolté
donc je sais que je vais être un
camarade de jeu au gouvernement un peu
exigeant un peu emmerdant pour dire les
choses euh on verra la premierre
ministre qui va venir dans la journée
d'ailleurs je tiens à dire que elle est
là pour me soutenir dans un combat fou
le combat de
l'eau à l'heure où je vous parle de
jours sur TR le robinet est fermé et je
peux pas tout dire vous accepteriez vous
lorsque l'électricité est coupée 2
heures en métropole on dit pas en
métropole on dit dans l'Hexagone ça
suscite naturellement lire absolu en
disant c'est scandaleux que font-ils
donc le premier combat je me suis donné
15 mois ça peut paraître une éternité
pour faire en sorte qu'on soit plus
soumis aux allias climatiques pour enfin
que la ressource en eau soit suffisante
voyez et puis en fait l'état se
substitue complètement aux éus locaux
voyez aussi quelque part ça amène à
avoir un œil attentif sur la
décentralisation quelquefois lorsqu'elle
est pas bien gérer localement le
deuxième drame que j'ai découvert et
hier soir j'avais le président de la
Ligue nationale contre le cancer qui
m'appelle mais oui dans les territoires
ultramarins il y a deux fois plus de
cancer et surtout le temps de prise en
charge est tr qu voire 5 fois plus
important que dans l'Hexagone je vais en
faire un deuxième chantier considérable
le trè sujet je regarde François ancien
minist d' l'éducation nationale Rachida
tu en as beaucoup parlé et je sais que
tout à l'heure vous aurez miséducation
qui a entrepris lui aussi un combat il
est allé je crois avec force sur sur la
BAA mais il ira sur d'autres thèmes j'ai
découvert qu' mayillotte mais ce que je
dis est un peu vrai mais maot c'est
tellement spectac
il y a des gamins qu'on le bat qui ne
savent pas ni écrire ni compter ça me
rappelle un bouquin de Françis Baayou la
décennie des malapis imaginez le
chantier et puis voyez le débat que
j'avais autour d'une table parce que le
préfet je lui avais demandé vous mettez
autour de la table des hommes et des
femmes qui peuvent pas laisser tout cela
se dérouler sans s'indigner et ils m'ont
dit je vous en supplie to Rachida ça
nous renvoie au débat sur l'immigration
et tu me permettras d'en dire un mot
sous le liatentif de mon président de
groupe Jean-Paul Matth qui est là et de
tous les collègues que je que je vois
avec bonheur ils m'ont dit je vous en
supplie dites bien qu'à Paris les gamins
qui sont en situation irrégulière qu'on
les mette à l'école qu'on continue de
les inscrire qu'on continue de les
former et de leur apprendre le calcul
l'écriture de maîtriser la langue et ma
plus grande joie c'était il y a 15
jours j'étais à Marie passoula en Guyane
lorsque j'ai inauguré la première école
connectée imaginez des gamins des
collégiens à 2 heures des Pirog les uns
des autres qui en même temps 800000 € on
a mis vraiment des super systèmes vidéos
numérisés et ils apprenaient exactement
la même chose à la même seconde fallait
voir la banane de ces gamins fallait
voir la générosité de la communauté
éducative donc vous voyez quand on parle
d'égalité des chances j'ai pris ces
trois exemples et je pour en prendre un
4è qui est sensible pour moi j'ai perdu
mon meilleur ami comme ça accident de
voiture accident de voiture sachez que
dans tous les territoires ultramarins
c'est deux à trois fois plus de morts
sur les routes et donc on va lancer avec
jean-ude je vous l'annonc aujourd'hui
qui est le vous savez le représentant de
l'ONU pour la sécurité routière une
opération dans tous les territoires
ultramarins et bien mon cher Patrick en
fait je crois que c'est le problème de
la volonté c'est la volonté de vos
parcours la volonté de cette famille
politique qui est debout malgré qu'à un
moment ou un autre tout le monde a voulu
la mettre par terre la volonté de de
résister et là je voudrais juste
terminer mon propos là-dessus en parlant
de l'immigration si j'étais encore
député mais chez que mes super copains
et copines députés le feront ne lâchez
pas ne lâchez pas entre ceux qui vous
disent on régularise tout le monde et
puis après on s'assoit sur la misère on
dit voyez on est généreux on les met
dans une boîte c'est scandaleux vous les
avez reconnu les amis de de Mélenchon
que vous connaissez tous très bien il y
a les autres qui vous disent du RN on
régularise personne après on peut avoir
des différences Rachida mais les chemins
de l'intelligence doivent nous conduire
sur un chemin qui sera celui qui
permettra de trouver la belle solution
entre toi et nous et les autres nous
disent on régularise personne mais on
met tout le monde dehors et là j'ai
pardonnez-moi une vieille litote que je
ressors à Mayotte je vois le président
du conseil de l'ordre lundi qui me dit
mon nous on peut plus soigner les gens
on a plus de médecin les seuls qui sont
là c'est des pasadus sa peut-être pas
tous ce que c'est c'est des médecins
étrangers qu diplôme hors Union
Européenne mais si je les mets tous
dehors je n'ai plus un patient que je
prends en charge sur le territoire
français parce que maot c'est la France
donc voyez tous ces extrêmes nous
conduit dans une impasse folle alors là
on est à un moment et je termine
vraiment un moment très important on a 4
ans pour redonner crédit à ces valeurs
de la République crédit à cette
intelligence collective que nous portons
malgré nos différences de sensibilité
d'abord si on pensait tout la même chose
comme dirait une personnalité célèbre on
penserait plus rien mais au-delà du fait
que nous avons quelques différences on a
entre nous l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est
la République et la République c'est la
France
alors avant de venir sur le l'école de
la deuxième chance avec avec Afida qui
va nous parler
justement de toutes les capacités ou au
cours d'une vie on peut redonner des
occasions de rencontrer la promesse
républicaine je voudrais entendre Rachel
justement sur
l'action celle qui permet de d'incarner
le la promesse
républicaine dans des champs qui sont
pas toujours explorés comme par exemple
celui de la culture mais beaucoup plus
largement en mastercl comme vous savez
le
faire merci beaucoup évidemment que je
rejoins l'ensemble des personnalités qui
ont qui ont pris la parole
fortement mais l'action l'action c'est
comme le disait Anna arent c'est aussi
le verbe et
aujourd'hui beaucoup crient à la
dictature et à la censure mais pour
redonner justement cet élan à la
République je crois qu'il faut lutter et
c'est pour ça qu'on est là je crois
aujourd'hui contre
l'autocensure c'est que aujourd'hui on a
peur de parler on a peur de redire les
mots qui sont dans la Constitution on a
peur de dire le mot transmission on a
peur de dire le mot patrimoine c'est
comme si ce qu'il y avait dans la
Constitution était devenu d'extrême
droite bon moi je suis pas forcé je suis
pas courageuse je je porte je tente de
porter les principes qui sont des
principes
constitutionnel et il y a des mots et
c'est vrai que ces mots il faut pas les
remplacer je
crois c'est vrai que le ministre de
l'Éducation a eu ce ce combat très fort
et très symbolique mais par
exemple il parle de cours de d'empathie
et je trouve dommage qu'il ait pas
rappelé ce mot qui est le la
fraternité je crois que ce mot-là qui
est trop peu exploité qui fait partie de
notre devise républicaine il mériterait
euh d'être appris dès la maternelle en
même temps que les cours les maths le
français et cetera ce qui est la
fraternité la fraternité c'est un droit
et c'est aussi un
devoir ensuite dans l'action évidemment
il y a ce mot citoyenneté qui devrait
impulser tout l'ensemble des politiques
de manière transversal euh et
interdisciplinaire et enfin pour
répondre à votre question Rachida vous
avez parlé de de Tavernier je crois que
les artistes sont les législateurs de
l'ombre et que par rapport à notre pacte
républicain les valeurs humanistes
universalistes mais au fond la
transmission des lumièr on ne peut pas
faire sans les artistes et aujourd'hui
beaucoup parlent d'une bataille
culturelle sans jamais parler de culture
et sans jamais parler d'artistes ce qui
est attaqué
c'est la culture notre pacte républicain
c'est un trésor
immatériel qui est un patrimoine
immatériel au fond et en sous-texte si
nos artistes ne sont plus là pour dire
certaines choses mettre en lumière
certaines choses dans les intuitions du
monde comme le disait Albert Camu que
les artistes sont embarqués dans les
galères de leur temps c'est ça et
aujourd'hui la culture est attaquée par
un soft power américain mais d'autres
pays
aussi par des influenceurs de haine qui
se font passer pour des artistes tout
n'est pas l'équivalent de tout tik
tookok c'est pas Beethoven c'est pas
vrai et ça on doit l'apprendre aussi à
l'école donc voilà moi c'est c'est ça
serait ma réponse qui en sousexte en
fait du Trésor républicain du pacte
républicain doit conforter les œuvres
notre patrimoine moi j'ai adoré faire la
visite avec François Baayou à peau par
exemple parce que dans les lumières
c'était entrreemêlé et et si on veut
transmettre le discernement
l'émerveillement et bien on a besoin des
artistes et la citoyenneté c'est un un
émerveillement et notre parcours à tous
c'est vrai que j'ai beaucoup de
peut-être de résonance dans mon parcours
avec celui de Rashida avec des
grands-parents qui étaient puisqu'on
parlait d'immigration des grands parents
maternel qui était à patride puis la
vague après les déc les indépendances du
côté de mon père avec cette évolution en
fait de l'immigration dont on a parlé
hier ces générations d'immigration qui
ne se ressemblent pas on doit
aussi
revenir à ces artistes qui nous ont
raconté les immigrations et ça c'est à
transmettre et moi je je pense que ça
donne un
décor puissant au cadre de de l'action
politique dans ce que nous avons à faire
euh
l'esthétique je pense que l'homme peut
mourir pour
l'esthétique et que le pacte républicain
la liberté l'égalité la fraternité
l'égalité la justice la transmission ce
sont des esthétiques immatérielles pour
lesquelles nous pouvons mourir alors en
fait je ne suis pas courageuse c'est
juste que je ne peux pas faire autrement
que de me battre pour cela compte tenu
de de mon
pédigré bon alors à ce moment du débat
on on chemine en progress et on voit que
pour pour défendre le pacte républicain
il faut défendre ses valeurs que ses
valeurs se transformment en promesse et
en efficacité et qu'on soit capable de
transmission euh également et c'est là
que je vaux appeler
Afida si elle veut bien monter sur la
scène avec nous elle est coordinatrice
de l'école de la deuxème chance Afida
Mead
elle va venir apporter un témoignage sur
le service national universel puis elle
peut nous parler aussi de la deième
chance parce que s'il y a bien une des
valeurs importantes pour la République
ou allez vous mettre là-bas ou il y a un
peu de lumière vos yeux vont
s'habituer et dans 10 secondes vous
allez pouvoir nous parler tranquillement
bah écoutez je voulais déjà vous
remercier de participer donc à cette à
cette action en tout cas à cette
réflexion sur les en tout cas note les
valeurs fondatrices de notre pacte
républicain alors oui je suis Madame M
donc responsable et coordinatrice des
écoles de la deuxième chance sur loise
il y en a qu'une alors juste pour
historique pour recentrer l'école de la
deuxè chance
était un constat suite au Livre blanc de
notre ancienne ministre madame édit
cresson et qui a fait un constat de ces
échecs scolaires dans un premier temps
et l'égalité des chances la première est
née sur Marseille et ensuite sur lîle
euh et on est arrivé à à aujourd'hui
plus de 140 structur au volet national
et on en a quelques-unes sur le volet
européen donc en Espagne et au Portugal
donc
l'objectif pour nous de ces tous ces
jeunes au départ qui étit donc
uniquement pour des jeunes de 18 à 25
ans qui s'est élargi au fur à mesure des
temps donc ce que je je rejoins un peu
ce que disait Madame Dati c'est que au
fur et à mesure du temps on est sur une
des problématiques où il n'y a pas eu de
solution de départ donc je ne comprends
pas et ça c'est aussi l'histoire qui qui
nous dira les cheminements qu'on est en
train de mettre en place auprès de cette
jeunesse des quartiers puisque là on axe
donc je suis sur crille où on a vraiment
donc un historique les premières filles
voilées c'est de là qui est partie
vraiment tout tout ce combat d'égalité
de de respect de la laïcité je le
reprends bien pour voilà se dire comment
je m'instruis et comment je m'engage à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui auprès de cette
société et moi ce que je m'aperçois
c'est que ces jeunes n'ont aucune
connaissance des valeurs fondatrices du
PACT républicain donc à chaque action
qu'on mène auprès de ces jeuneslà c'est
de partir de l'histoire vous imaginez de
l'histoire de France où on est en train
de travailler sur qu'est-ce que on est
passé quand même de la monarchie à la
République qu'est-ce qu'on met en place
à l'ORS d'aujourd'hui et qu'est-ce que
la valeur républicaine la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité mais déjà où se
situe la liberté des uns quand commence
celle des autres qui suis-je par rapport
à l'égalité aujourd'hui l'égalité des
chances j'habite dans un quartier qpv
j'habite pas dans la ruralité est-ce que
je suis prêt à l'emploi et là je rejoins
aussi ce qu'on disait c'est bien de
définir qu'il y a des métiers
sousension mais il y a des gens qui
veulent travailler sur ces métiers là
mais a une mesconnaissances des métiers
donc la région retravaille encore cette
année sur un nouveau prototype pour
essayer de mettre en place le lien
emploi jeune et ça c'est un que je mène
depuis plus de 20 ans près de la
jeunesse de l'Oise des Haut- de France
et pas que pour apprendre ou en tout cas
leur donner toutes ces valeurs à ces
jeunesl et de leur dire que tout est
possible et si on narrive pas nous déjà
avec notre parcours parce que là aussi
j'ai un parcours de vie je pense que là
j'ai entendu différents témoignages ou
on me disait que tu n'y arriveras pas et
alors d'aujourd'hui j'ai pu être chef
d'entreprise j'ai pu être êre dans le
domaine aussi de
l'insertion et je donne la chance à tous
ces jeunesl et moi ce qui m'inquiète je
vous le cache pas c'est qu'on est arrivé
à une obligation de formation depuis
l'année dernière donc j'accueille des
jeunes de 16 à 18 ans et voir maintenant
des jeunes de 25 à 30 ans donc les
écoles de la deuxème chance sont
ouvertes donc pour les 16 à 30 ans et
depuis l'année dernière avec Monsieur
Castex on a pu travailler aussi sur
normalement je ne devrais pas avoir des
bacheliers comment cela se fait que des
jeunes bacheliers voire bac+ 2 ne sont
pas à l'emploi et on sait qu'il y a de
l'emploi sur le territoire donc voilà le
grand combat que je mène al l'heure
d'aujourd'hui auprès de cette population
merci Marie-Pierre une réaction sur sur
ces obligations de de
transmission et sur la capacité
aussi de redonner des impulsions pour
avoir une deuxème ou une troisème chance
d'intégration sociale dans notre
pays merci beaucoup de votre témoignage
je pense que ça ça fait totalement écho
justement dans ce que vous avez dit au
aux différents témoignages et on voit
bien qu'effectivement l'école comme vous
l'avez dit c'est la merre de toutes les
batailles pour justement donner des
perspectives d'avenir et et pour
justement aussi parce qu'il y a plein de
points que vous évoquez dans votre dans
votre témoign il y a effectivement la
transmission des valeurs il y a
l'adéquation entre le monde de la
formation et la réalité des entreprises
et on voit bien aussi moi j'en suis le
parfait exemple mes parents m'ont poussé
à faire le lycée général les formations
générales sans trop savoir ce que
j'allais faire et j'ai rencontré par
contre les bonnes personnes au bon
moment et ça c'est pas donné à tout le
monde aussi de rencontrer les bonnes
personnes au bon moment François
baayerou Marielle de Sarnez ja François
lutin qui font que votre vie du jour au
lendemain elle change totalement c'est
ce que vous avez évoqué pourquoi vous et
pas vos camarades de palier des vies
totalement différentes c'est ça en fait
l'école de la 2uxième change c'est
donner aussi des clés donner des clés
parce qu'en fait on n'est pas confronté
tous aux mêmes PES aussi on n'est pas
confronté au mêm verrou et et on voit
aussi que justement parfois on manque
d'agilité justement notre notre pacte
républicain il a ses fondamentaux il a
ses socles mais il faut pour qu'il
puisse s'adapter à toutes les réalités
Philippe évoqué les outremèes les
réalités territorial ne sont pas les
mêmes quand vous êtes en Bretagne en
ruralité quand vous êtes en Outremer
quand vous êtes en banlieu parisienne
les réalités ne sont pas les mêmes et ça
je pense que c'est c'est quelque chose
aussi qui est très important pour notre
mouvement et sur lequel on doit
absolument travailler pour donner des
perspectives plus ouvertes à tout le
monde et toujours transmettre son
message parce que vois bien quand on
échange avec plein de jeunes en fait ils
se mettent déjà plein de barrières
eux-mêmes ceci n'est pas pour moi parce
que tel ou tel telle raison ceci ne sera
jamais accessible pour telle ou telle
raison et on doit renouer aussi avec ce
discours du tout est
possible est-ce que Rachid adati peut
nous dire un mot du rôle des élus
locaux dans
cette dans cet enjeu dans cette
ambition de trouver des solutions
d'efficacité pour les politiques
publiques parce que ce au cours de quoi
on tourne depuis quelques dizaines de
minutes c'est que ben si on veut être à
la hauteur de la promesse il faut
trouver une action publique efficace et
à quel niveau elle doit être le plus
efficace et quels en sont les freins ce
que ce que disait ce que vous disiez
madame à propos de l'école de la deuxème
chance je me souviens parce que nous
l'avion lancé avec edit cresson en est à
l'origine et avec Simone veille et
ensuite le relais avait été pris je me
souviens par Martine Aubri avec la
Fondation agir de lutte contre
l'exclusion et en fait on s'est rendu
compte que heureusement qu'on avait des
personnalité comme ça qui connaissaiit
très bien le maillage territorial qui
connaissaiit très bien les institutions
et donc qui connaissaiit très bien les
connexion nécessaire et c'est là o on
s'est rendu compte que effectivement on
pouvait encore sortir de la
désintégration ou de la désinsertions ou
de l'exclusion bah des jeunes qui
n'avaient pas vocation à être exclus
parce qu'ils étaient très méritants et
très volontaires là-dessus moi je je
veux vous dire sur le rôle des élus
locaux je je vais y venir notamment sur
sur les maires lorsque j'étais Gard des
saut j'ai créé ce qu'on appelle les
classes préparatoires intégrées et
d'ailleurs il y avait un journal de
gauche qui en avait fait la promotion et
quand je l'aurais dit ben j'en avais été
à l'origine c'est juste il m'a pas dit
bah si on avait su on l'aurait pas fait
donc voilà donc ça vous en diton sur le
côté un peu sectaire de de de cette
gauche qui en fait et Rachel va
comprendre je pense que ça les dérange
c'estàd que il pensent que nous sommes
des anomalies à droite voilà donc c'est
cet aspect-l
et les classes préparatoires intégrées
c'était de dire quoi c'était de dire
Jean-Pierre jeevénem avait fait les
adjoints de sécurité par le bas en
disant on va prendre les adjoints de
sécurité qui étaient effectivement après
pouvait devenir des policiers municipaux
ou autes nous on a pris par le haut on a
dit on va prendre des étudiants
extrêmement méritants mais qui n'ont pas
les moyens de faire des classes
préparatoires parce que vous le savez
pour faire des classes préparatoires
vous avez intérêt à avoir un peu
l'esprit libre et donc pas avoir de
contrainte matérielle donc on avait pris
des boursiers on leur dit on leur paye
les classes préparatoirees et il prépare
tous les grands concours de la fonction
publique aujourd'hui vous avez des
classes préparatoires intégrées je les
ai faites pour toutes les écoles de
justice magistrat greffi fonctionnaire
pénitentiaire pour tous ces étudiants en
droit méritant et ils sont pris en
charge ils font une prépa ils passent le
concours comme tout le monde parce que
moi je ne suis pas favorable à ce qu'il
ait des concours 2e zone euh ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point les a
fait pour les écoles de police ça marche
très très bien ça c'est des facteurs
d'intégration et pour des gens qui
parfois eux-mêmes n'avaient pas pensé à
la magistrature parce que j'avais été
frappé dans la magistrature il y a moins
de 5 % d'enfants d'ouvriers qui sont
magistrats on est beaucoup dans la
reproduction sociale sur le rôle des
élus locaux euh on a fait adopter un
texte le 5 mars 2007 un loi sur la
prévention de la délinquence c'est un
texte qui consacrait toutes les
expérimentation qui avait mis en œuvre
les élus locaux dans leur région dans
leur département dans leurs villes lutte
contre l'absentisme scolaire le
signalement parce que ce qui reste
aujourd'hui qui est un angle mort pour
ce gouvernement mais depuis longtemps
c'est euh la protection de l'enfance je
m'explique le Conseil euh des droits et
devoirs que nous avons
créé lorsque nous étions au pouvoir
c'est le c'est le maire qui le réunit
qui permet de convoquer les familles de
voir les enfants et d'aider soit
d'orienter les enfants ou d'aider les
familles notamment les familles
monoparentales en difficulté voilà le
rôle de l'élu local ça aide aussi à cela
ça permet aussi de faire la connexion
entre par exemple le rectorat l'école la
mairie mais aussi la Mission Locale
quand vous savez que la mission locale
ne travaille pas avec les académies il y
a pas de connexion les mission locales
c'est fait pour des jeunes c'est 16 25
ans il n'y a pas de connexion et donc on
a expérimenté je me rappelle parce que
la première ville où nous l'avions fait
c'était Cronembourg de mettre une
connexion pour que les enfants qui sont
enfin les jeunes qui sont à la Mission
Locale puissent être aidé par le
rectorat pourquoi pour pouvoir les
raccrocher sur des formations si
nécessaire ça c'était ce point-là mais
aussi que le rectorat puisse signaler
tous les décrocheurs scolaires ou les
sortants scolaire à partir de 16 ans
parce que vous savez que parfois il y a
des enfants qui sont pas forcément
adaptés au système de scolaire classique
et donc on les traîne on les traîne on
les traîn jusqu'à 16 ans et après ils
partent le rectorat les académies les
académies ne les recensent pas et ils
sont dans la nature donc ils n'ont pas
forcément de droit pas animnité et tout
et donc c'est voilà le rôle de l'élu
local qu'on avait consacré dans le dans
la la loi de 2007 c'était effectivement
cette coordination là et qui y avait
incialement autre chose le partage de
l'information regardez moi quand j'étais
Gard des saut j'ai et d'ailleurs on en
avait parlé avec François j'ai rédigé un
code de la justice des mineurs qu'est-ce
qu'on entend quand on dit code de la
justice des mineurs on entend code de la
justice pénale des mineurs oui j'ai
réformé la la justice pénale des mineurs
mais le problème des mineurs en France
la délinquence des mineurs elle est
minoritaire c'est la protection de
l'enfance la protection de l'enfance
c'est un scandale d'État la maltraitance
même le harcèlement fait partie de cette
maltraitance des mineurs aujourd'hui il
y a des inégalités flagrantes sur tout
le territoire et quand pour ceux qui
sont magistrats moi ça m'est arrivé de
placer des enfants dans des endroits et
je savais qu'il allait être maltraité
parce que on n pas une politique
nationale de la lutte contre la
maltraitance des mineurs ça c'est un
enjeu majeur aujourd'hui nous n'avons
pas de politique de protection de l'F
enfance ça n'existe pas au niveau
national c'est quelque chose qui reste à
faire et là les ulocons ont tout leur
rôle ils connaissent les familles ils
connaissent les enfants ils sont en lien
avec l'école la petite fille qui est
morte battue par par les parents on a
dit qu'il y a eu une suspension la
directrice parce que effectivement il y
a pas eu de signalement ou peut-être
a-t-elle fait un signalement mais ça n'a
pas été repris pourquoi parce que les
travailleurs sociaux dans chaque
organisme la CAF l'école la mairie euh
et puis au niveau du quartier ne se
coordonne pas il n'y a pas de partage
d'information alors qu'on l'a consacré
juridiquement pourquoi parce que chacun
travaille dans son couloir et il ne sait
pas qu'il y a eu des signalement
ailleurs notre grande victoire ça a été
fait pour les femmes victimes de
violence c'est pour ça que sur la
maltraitance des enfants c'est encore un
sujet sur lequel on est très mal à
l'aise je pense il y a encore beaucoup
trop de tabou regardez la commission sur
l'inceste moi je serais favorable
qu'elle qu'elle persiste et qu'elle soit
pérenne parce que là elle devait
remettre son rapport c'est c'est une
réalité en France et donc comme nous
l'avons fait pour les femmes victimes de
violence de s'en emparer de ne pas
laisser d'angle mort c'est qu'on le
fasse aussi pour les enfants et
notamment beaucoup d'enfants meurent
sont maltraités alors qu'on a la
formation alors qu'on a les signalements
je vous invite à regarder que tous les
enfants maltraités souvent ont été
majoritairement signalés mais évidemment
le dossier n'a pas été suivi donc la
protection de l'enfance reste un sujet
et là les élus locaux nous on a notre
rôle puisqu'on est en lien avec les
écoles on inscrit les enfants on reçoit
les familles et donc ça c'est un
évidemment c'est un rôle majeur et c'est
un rôle majeur notamment pour
l'insertion parce que beaucoup d'enfants
qui sont maltraités bah ça finit mal au
bout du au bout du bout du bout du
compte et donc ça c'est c'est une
réalité à laquelle on devrait
s'intéresser moi je souviens et je j'en
terminerai par là sur les femmes
victimes de violence quand on a porté la
loi de 2004 y compris la majorité à
laquelle j'appartenait euh c'était
l'éviction du conjoint violent du
domicile la droite n'avait pas voulu lui
le porter la droite et toute la famille
politique pourquoi parce qu'on avait dit
c'est pas constitutionnel et moi je me
souviens j'avais dit mais est-ce que
c'est constitutionnel que la femme sorte
avec les enfants ou qu'elle soit mise
dehors à moitié morte avec ses gamins
est-ce que ça c'est constitutionnel et
le texte a été adopté sur une
proposition de loi communiste qu'on a
appuyé et donc maintenant c'est dans la
loi l'éviction du conjoint violent ça a
été déclaré constitutionnel l'autre
sujet ça a été effectivement euh moi je
voulais que les médecins parce que les
femmes qui sont victimes de violence et
j'en sais quelque chose notamment par
euh par nos parcours personnel on a vu
autour de nous elles vont pas chez au
commissa de police déposer plainte
contre le mari hein mais elles en
parlent à la PMI
elles en parlent aux médecins elles en
parlent aux médecins qui suit le gamin
en disant oui c'est mon mari regardez et
moi j'avais demandé àce que les médecins
puissent signaler même sans le
consentement de la victime ça a été
compliqué on avait fait la moitié du
chemin là auour' aujourd'hui le chemin a
été fait totalement c'est important et
une autre victoire que j'ai souhaité
avoir et ça je l'avais demandé à Mariel
chapela qui l' portter c'était
l'interdiction des certificats de
virginité personne moi je sou bien
Nicolas Abou président du commission des
affaires sociales au Sénat était contre
il considè que c'est un acte médical
j'ai dit un acte un certificat de
virginité n'est pas un acte médical je
suis désolé parce que quand vous avez
des filles qui sont obligées sous la
coupe d'un père d'un frérot d'aller
faire un certificat de virginité avant
une demande mariage et autre je trouve
que c'est une atteinte grave mais la
dignité des femmes et ça l'abrogation du
certificat de virginité ça date là il y
a à peine à peine un an donc ces combats
là c'est des petits combats mais c'est
ce sont des combats vitaux et important
N'oubliez pas sur la protection de
l'enfance on a décidément vraiment bien
fait de vous inviter puisque vous faites
compris par que je voulais qu'on envoie
la vidéo de pine Goulet qui est notre
présidente de la délégation au droits
des enfants à l'Assemblée nationale
précisément donc si vous pouvez envoyer
cette vidéo parce que per pouvait pas
être avec nous aujourd'hui ce sera
l'occasion de d'achever notre débat par
des mots de conclusion ensuite que je
vous demanderai les uns et les
autres le pacte républicain celui des
enfants est sans doute le plus important
c'est celui de permettre à chaque enfant
quelle que soit son origine ou sa
couleur de peau de pouir trouver sa dans
notre société depuis 2007 nous avons
déjà beaucoup fait mais nous devons
encore agir les 1000 premiers jours ont
été une avancée considérable mais il
faut qu'on aille plus loin qu'on
soutienne encore plus les parents dans
le soutien à la parentalité est une
nécessité pour pouvoir aider les parents
à mieux accompagner leurs enfants à
l'école le dédoublement des classes a
déjà agi mais quit des autres enfants
nous devons réduire le nombre d'enfants
par classe afin que chacune et chacun
puisse acquérir les notions
fondamentales qui seront nécessaires
dans son
avenir que dire du sport de la culture
nous avons besoin que chaque enfant y a
accès nous avons également besoin que
chaque enfant puisse avir les
sensibilisations de notre époque
l'Internet l'éducation au corps pour se
faire peut-être une heure de plus par
jour à l'école pour permettre aux
intervenants extérieurs de venir
prodiguer ses enseignements et notre
jeunesse elle a besoin de connaître les
métiers les métiers que nous avons
besoin dans notre société nous devons
leur permettre de choisir leur
orientation et pas de la
subir mais également leur permettre de
découvrir découvrir l'Europe chacune et
chacun devrait pouvoir aller en Europe
quelle que soit sa condition familiale
et sociale ainsi comme je vous le dis
pour moi le pacte républicain le plus
important c'est celui des enfants ils
sont les citoyens de demain ils sont
notre avenir ensemble faisons plus pour
les
enfants
on peut être très fier d'avoir pine à la
présidence de la délégation au droits
des enfants qui elle-même par son
parcours vous la connaissz les députés
de la Nièvre c'est un parcours d'enfant
placé qui a réussi et qui aujourd'hui va
essayer de concevoir des politiques
publiques pour répondre précisément à
cet angle mort de des politiques que
nous conduisons cher Philippe sur ce
sujet de l'enfance mais bien au-delà et
et en quelques mots de
conclusion je te laisse la parle
bien c'est un un moment difficile parce
que après l'intervention de pine et
celle de Rachida je disait tout à
l'heure que c'est un beau débat que nous
avons des débats comme je les aime où
chacun avec ses fibres son parcours et
donne un peu sa vision et comment on
peut en fait si on est là c'est quelque
part on est acteur et je pense que je
vrais juste dire trois choses d'abord
rendre hommage au monde associatif
qui joue un rôle absolument formidable
et qui est actuellement fragilisé voyez
juste avant de partir de Mayot j'ai
rencontré la directrice générale de la
Croix-Rouge qui était à Mayotte et qui
m'a alerté pas simplement sur la misère
que nous voyons grandir ça est là pas
simplement sur des drames familiaux de
toute nature que vous connaissez aussi
bien que moi si ce n'est mieux mais sur
aussi le fait que l'engagement commence
à manquer et on le voit dans les
associations sportives culturelles alors
tout le monde dit c'est le covid non
mais dans les partis politiques dans les
syndicats et quelque part je cou que la
République c'est aussi l'engagement et
l'engagement associatif tout à l'heure
tu disais for justement Rachel il faut
une voix faut incarner bien je pense que
la voix et l'incarnation ça serait à
nouveau d'avoir une grande voie
associative et peut-être le Parlement
nous sommes là on avait je souvien sur
une précédente mandature travailler sur
le rôle que l'on pourrait donner en
responsabilité en reconnaissance c'est
un mot qu'on ne prononce plus j'aime ce
mot
reconnaissance je crois que là-dessus il
y a une piste me semble-t-il à emprunter
Rachida tu parlais d'un deuxième sujet
qui tient beaucoup à mon cœur c'est tu
as parlé des écoles de la magistrature
des parcours d'intération comment on
pouvait inventer des nouveaux parcours
regardez les métiers de la santé tout le
monde parle d'un drame terrible c'est de
l'accès aux soins de la désertification
médicale j'avais suggéré modestement
avec d'autres qu' une sorte d'école
nationale des métier de la santé on m'a
dit au ministère c'est trop compliqué
c'est technique faut des référents des
machins bref on n' pas pu faire et
j'imaginais faire comme l'éducation
nationale avait su le faire je regarde
François avec les ipè tu t'en souviens
moi j'ai une cousine qui est agrégé de
math ses parents n'avaient aucun moyen
mais elle a été payée pendant ses études
c'est une super prof ce que tu as voulu
faire pour la magistrature faisons-le
pour l'ensemble de ces métiers de la
santé savez-vous 50 % des écoles
d'infirmièr en première année il y a des
amandons au bout d'une année parce
qu'ils sont pas dans l'AMB parcours donc
il faut réinventer ces métiers là parce
que si on embrasse un jour les métiers
de la santé on les embrasse parce que on
a une volonté il y en a quelque chose de
différent que on a envie de faire cela
et la troisième chose c'était il y a 3
mois il se trouve que j'ai eu la chance
d'aider à l'implantation d'une
entreprise dans ma circonscription et on
m'avait dit je vais que vous veniez en
direct assister à des
recrutements et là sur l'affaire de
l'anonimisation vous savez pour les
CV et donc j'ai autorisé un candidat à
prendre mon nom et mon
prénom
il a été en il a eu droit un deuxème
entretien
d'embauche et comme j'étais de mèche
avec le patron je lui ai fait passer les
deux tests à la fois en s'appelant je
vous dirai après mon petit comité et en
s'appelant Philippe Vig là je me suis
c'est pas possible et franchement ça ça
crée une frustration ce gamin depuis
parce qu'il a 20 ans a parlé partout à
châteauin chez moi il a dit me rendez
compte j'ai pris le nom du député minist
depuis et comme ça en plus il a trouvé
le boulot là on a une respons abilité
collective à
parcours pardon à diplôme égal on
s'aperçoit que et bien on les laisse sur
le bord de la route et C histoire est
raconter au café est raconter dans la
rue elle crée des frustrations et bien
c'est le modèle républicain pour revenir
au thème de cette belle rencontre qui
était bréché essayons de faire œuvre
ensemble pourtant on croyez pas qu'en
s'appelant PHPP Vig on pouvait monter
comme ça dans la vie hein mais je ça
mais ça marche
Rachel non mais cet exemple est est très
important et pour revenir à à ce mes
propos
liminires c'est véritablement martelé
sur le fait
que certains partis politiques de
l'extrême n'ont pas le monopole de la
lutte contre les
discriminations
l'égalité devant la loi et c'est vrai
que ça me fait penser
[Musique]
aussi à ses droits et ses devoirs
c'est-à-dire
que lorsque la République vous donne
c'est aussi en ce sens que vous pouvez
lui redonner et nous en responsabilité
par cette transmission
absolument et la citoyenneté est un
effort et c'est grâce à l'effort qu'on
peut en être fier et je terminerai
simplement par
des propos que me que me rappelle mon
père régulièrement et qui font écho à
l'art et à la culture il me répète
souvent que
l'origine d'un homme c'est la
bibliothèque et que dans la bibliothèque
il y a ce pacte républicain fait de
récits des citoyens je voulais terminer
par
ça
Marie-Pierre si tu as de nouvelles
récriminations pour l'école Gabriel Atal
va pas tarder donc c'est le moment de
recharger un peu la haute qui était déjà
pas mal chargé par achida Dati voilà oui
je pense que là beaucoup beaucoup de
choses on ont été dites sur l'école mais
quoi on le voit bien justement c'est
c'est véritablement là où tout doit se
jouer et où tout commence en fait mais
tout commence à l'école mais tout
commence aussi à la maison et ça je
pense qu'aussi on doit pas l'oublier
parce que tout les mots qui ont ont été
dit et qui ont été mis en exerg aussi
c'est véritablement notre responsabilité
individuelle et collective et l'un va
avec l'autre et que justement quand on
travaille à l'heure où tout se développe
autour de l'individualisme en fait on
démontre bien
que finalement c'est quand on est certes
dans notre individualisme au service du
collectif que véritablement on arrive à
avancer tous ensemble et ça je crois
qu'on l'a perdu de vue et on ne le
transmet pas suffisamment aussi à
l'échelle de l'Europe vous avez évoqué
justement cette volonté d'avoir des
cours d'empathie moi ça m'a un peu
surprise comme annonce euh je suis pas
sûre que ça soit juste de l'empathie qui
faille véritablement mettre à l'école
c'est pas ça qui fera justement
complètement changer les éléments qu'on
qu'on a évoqué les uns les autres donc
oui je pense qu'il faut qu'on aille plus
loin quand même dans notre travail pour
réformer l'Europe et réformer
l'école les chers Rachida je vous laisse
le le mot de la fin
pour conclure d'abord je voudrais à
nouveau remercier François baayrou et M
Gatel et Béatrice le
couturier qui combat avec moi à Paris et
nous avons d'ailleurs nous avons été sur
les mêmes listes en 2020 et on va
récidiver en 2026 parce que on a fait un
excellent travail et vraiment beratrice
merci d'être à mes côtés dans ce combat
parisien qui
devient un véritable combat et un combat
d'intérêt général d'intérêt public
public alors moi je vais vous dire vous
recevez le ministre de l'éducation
nationale je vais être pratique j'espère
qu'il va pas vous parler que de la
baaya j'espère qu'il va vous parler des
enseignants
euh face à des élèves que ce soit le bon
enseignant du bon niveau face à des
élèves comment il réduire les inégalités
comment on aide les enfants qui ont
moins qu' ont pas de parents qu' ont du
temps pour les devoirs ou qui
comprennent pas forcément comment on
fait les études dirigées qui ont été
abrogé par la gauche comment rétablir
les internats d'excellence qui ont été
supprimés par la gauche moi je suis
désespérée j'en ai encore un dans le 7e
arrondissement j'ai cré des internats
d'excellence de permettre à des enfants
méritants au collège d'être scolarisé
dans un internat pas très loin des
parents parce que quand on a 9 10 ans ou
10 11 ans bon on a encore on envie de sa
maman encore pas très loin mais parfois
la maman elle est un peu débordée et de
lui donner un un un endroit un peu
serein pour faire des études au collège
et ben c'est une belle promesse d'avenir
ces établissements ont été supprimé par
François Hollande et je le regrette
j'espère que les bourses aur mérit vont
être établies elles ont été supprimées
et j'espère que l'aide au devoir
individualisé va être rétabli donc
j'attends beaucoup de Gabriel Atal bravo
pour la Baya mais il y a pas que ça
voilà
et Philippe Vigier a redemander la
parole monsieur le ministre un demimot
et je regarde je bien d'Io et je regarde
Sarah
une note très positive et moi qui m'a
beaucoup touché le
RSMA le Service Militaire Adapté je suis
allé les voir dans six territoires
ultramarins à l'heure où je vous parle
ils sont en train de distribuer de l'eau
aux maoraais ou aux Maurais ces jeunes
si vous avez vu leur fierté que je
lisais dans les yeux formidable ça
faisait sens il SAV ils servent à
quelque chose ils servent la République
c'est un bel exemple et notre famille
politique a beaucoup aidé pour cela
merci beaucoup merci à tous donc on
compte sur vous pour tenir les promesses
républicaines sur le terrain et on se
retrouve dans quelques
minutes